you've seen how using momentum can speed
up gradient descent there's another
algorithm called rmsprop which stands
for root mean square prop they can also
speed up gradient descent let's see how
it works
recall our example from before that if
you implement gradient descent you can
end up with huge oscillations in the
vertical direction even while it's
trying to make progress in the
horizontal direction in order to provide
intuition for this example let's say
that the vertical axis is the parameter
B and the horizontal axis is the
parameter W and it really could be W 1
and W 2 or some of the center parameters
most names is BMW for the sake of
intuition and so you want to slow down
the learning in the B direction or in
the vertical direction and speed up
learning or at least not slow it down in
the horizontal direction so this is what
the rmsprop algorithm does to accomplish
this on iteration T it will compute as
usual the derivatives DWD be on the
currents mini-batch so lets going to
keep this sum exponentially weighted
average in step v DW I'm going to use
new notation s DW so s DW 0 to beta
times their previous value plus 1 minus
beta times DW squared
sometimes write this DW starts r22
generally expansion which invented this
PW squared so for clarity this squaring
operation is an element wise squaring
operation so what this is doing is
really keeping an exponentially weighted
average of the squares of the
derivatives and similarly we also have s
DB equals beta as DB plus 1 minus beta D
B squared and again the squaring is an
element-wise operation
rmsprop then updates the parameters as
follows w gets updated as w - the
learning rate and whereas previously we
had alpha a times DW now as DW divided
by square root of s DW and b gives
updated as b - a learning rate times
instead of just a gradient this is also
divided by now divided by s DB so let's
gain some intuitions about how this
works recall that in the horizontal
direction or in this example in the w
direction we want learning to go pretty
fast whereas in the vertical direction
run this example in the B direction we
want to slow down or to damp out the
oscillations in the vertical direction
so with these terms s DW as DB what
we're hoping is that SB W will be
relatively small so that here we're
dividing it by relatively small number
whereas DB would be relatively launched
so that here we're dividing by
relatively large number in order to slow
down the updates in the vertical
direction and indeed if you look at the
derivatives these derivatives are much
larger in the vertical direction than in
the horizontal direction so you know the
slope is very large in the B direction
right so with derivatives like this this
is a very large DB and a relatively
small DW because the function is sloped
much more steeply in the vertical
direction that is in the B direction
then in the W direction and the
horizontal direction and so DB squared
will be relatively large so as DB we're
relatively launch where as compared to
that DW will be smaller DW squared will
be smaller and so SB W be smaller so the
net effect of this is that your updates
in the vertical direction are divided by
a much larger number and so that helps
damp out the oscillations whereas the
updates in the horizontal direction are
divided by a smaller number so the net
impact of using rmsprop is as your
updates who end up looking more like
right that your update Cindy on vertical
direction get down tell but in
horizontal direction it can keep going
and one infected this is all so that you
could therefore use the larger learning
rate alpha and get faster learning
without the diverging in the vertical
direction now just for the sake of
clarity I've been calling the vertical
and horizontal directions B and W just
to illustrate this in practice you're in
a very high dimensional space of
parameters so maybe the vertical
dimensions when you're trying to dampen
oscillations is some set of parameters W
1 W 2 W 17 and the horizontal dimensions
might be W 3 w 4 u and so on right and
so the separation is a WMV is just an
illustration in practice DW is a very
high dimensional parameter vector DB is
also a very high dimensional parameter
vector but the intuition is that in
dimensions where you're getting these
oscillations you end up computing a
larger sum or weighted average for these
squares of derivatives and so you end up
damping out the directions in which
there are these oscillations so that's
rmsprop and it stands for root mean
squared because a root means square prop
because here you're squaring the
derivatives and then you take the square
root here at the end so finally just a
couple lost details on this algorithm
before we move on in the next video
we're actually going to combine rmsprop
together with momentum so rather than
using the hyper parameter beta which we
had used for momentum I'm going to call
this hyper parameter beta to just to not
clash or the same hyper parameter for
both momentum and for harmless problem
and also to make sure that your
algorithm doesn't divide by zero you
know one of square root of s DW right
it's very close to zero then this thing
could blow up just to ensure the
American stability when you implement
those in practice you have a very very
small epsilon to the denominator that
really matter what epsilon is use 10 to
the negative eight would be a reasonable
default but this just ensures slightly
greater numerical stability that you
know from numerical roundoff over the
reasons that you don't end up dividing
by a very small number so that's rmsprop
and similar to momentum as the effects
of damping out the oscillations in
gradient descent in meaning battery
under sense and allowing you to maybe
use a larger learning rate alpha and
certainly speeding up the learning speed
of your algorithm so now you know how to
implement rmsprop and this will be
another way for you to speed up your
learning algorithm one fun fact about
rmsprop
it was actually first proposed now the
academic research paper but in a cold
seven holes that geoff hinton had taught
on Coursera many years ago I guess
Coursera wasn't intended to be a
platform for dissemination of novel
academic research but it worked out
pretty well in that case it was really
from the Coursera course that rmsprop
start to become widely known and it
really took off we'll talk about
momentum which also rmsprop it turns out
that you put them together you can get
an even better optimization algorithm
let's talk about that in the next video